do you think you're going to cry when
the celtics lose
[Laughter]
i still think they're going to win i i
want to cry uh
that was tough that last game was tough
but
steph
is special but no steph's special but if
if you score like two points in the last
six minutes you're gonna lose to most
teams in the nba finals he's great yeah
and fun to watch and you realize even i
don't hate him i hate draymond i hate
clay i don't hate steph he didn't say
[ __ ] word the entire i actually said
one thing to him he turned because i had
seats right there i'm like you're gonna
have to do it yourself he'd look because
i know i am whoa
yeah whoa so like i don't man he did
you
know alpha bro
like i [ __ ] hate lebron i don't hate
stuff but again the celtics did what we
scored 18 points in the fourth quarter
you're not gonna win many nba finals
games scoring 18. all right quick before
you leave what do you what did you think
about the uh [ __ ] you draymond tran uh
chant
what's the furthest the audience can go
that is pg
that maybe gee
i mean and then his wife was like the
language dude you swore in front of your
kid at the podium
and he's got the clip on his podcast
being like
[ __ ] draymond no [ __ ] you he plays along
with it that's his vibe that's fine [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you draymond is nothing yeah
like nothing uh
i'm gonna [ __ ] your wife over the line
yeah like [ __ ] you draymond [ __ ] like
that in the seats there was one actually
weird
and i also think if players talk back
you can talk to them like a guy behind
a couple scrubs complaining the refs
he's like sit down and the golden state
security guy he's like you can't engage
with the fans meanwhile iguodala came
out and iguadola said to the guys like
it's okay he's yelling at to do he's
like they've never seen a black person
before well now you can engage with the
fans
but again i think the main i think the
main thing is
i get it because you're so close to the
players and you don't want it to go over
that line where it's like you know get a
mayhem at the palace where people are
getting punched right you
[ __ ] you draymond's nothing it's nothing
nothing i don't think there's anything
so there's a line but that's not the
line
yeah
by the way he brought it on himself i
mean he's a [ __ ] maniac he goes on
his podcast talk a ton of [ __ ] yeah so
come on you you don't
that's that
that's easy that's g that's not pg
that's g as long as you keep it towards
the player you don't go family it's not
threat you're not touching but [ __ ] you
draymond there's no one here who thinks
that's a problem when you were playing
baseball were you a good [ __ ] talker
you can't really talk [ __ ] in baseball i
mean because they can throw up baseball
yeah
because in the outfield yeah they're in
a field by myself yeah there's not you
know basketball football but basketball
is
that's obviously [ __ ] talking i mean
there's nobody everyone agrees right
[ __ ] you
yeah it's not that that's he's heard way
worse things and he's probably said way
worse things but i do think people cross
the line like sometimes i'll be there
and they are talking about wives they're
not they're talking about like bronze
kid and [ __ ] and it's like yeah i'll
leave the kid out of it the kid is 14
years old yeah let's just be honest i
mean
lebron did say
like
it wasn't
like he a big regret he didn't want his
kid to have too much pressure but he
named him lebron like junior so i mean
i mean
like he he's
running ha on to the court during his
games right right posting clips of them
so i
think you could talk everyone likes it
both ways wait are you saying lebron's a
hypocrite bro yeah are you are you
actually saying right maybe the old-time
hip-hop
yeah so it's a hot take right here
lebron james yeah right exactly so i
mean
he he's again most of the people i
really [ __ ] hate yeah are born out of
rivalries like that kg
rondo pierce they we went to war with
him and i hated him so much like that
celtic seems like my favorite basically
boston sports team ever i like i loved
how much
they they felt like me like they were
out there like the like ray allen the
way they [ __ ] hated him i'm like yes
yes
they were like fans so uh you know that
starred my hatred of him and then he's
the way he handled himself like the
decision and all that [ __ ] so i've been
a lebron hater like for a long time i
have an arc i have an article i think 27
reasons lebron james is the antichrist
[Laughter]
and you're a jew yeah
[Applause]